hallo herzlich willkommen meine taten
als er mich kennt ihr ja und meine
freundin makiadi kennt ihr auch schon
aus und bringt letzten gemeinsamen video
ja ich hab euch ja oder wir haben euch
erzählt dass wir zusammenhalten
topfgeldjäger antreten werden
wer jetzt die woche auch schon fleißig
geschaut ja ich war eine sehr spannende
wochen für uns zu sehen wer vor uns in
der woche kocht und haben auch gerade
eben noch die sendung gesehen als papa
und tochter ich weiß geheißen
gegen die zwei mädels angetreten sind
und an der stelle wollen wir natürlich
unseren glückwunsch aussprechen für
euro-käufe geht es ja und wir haben wir
gesagt dass wir ab nächster woche
antreten werden mussten aber noch nicht
genau wann und jetzt können wir euch
sagen wenn wir am dienstag antreten
werden werden nämlich einen anruf
bekommen und da eben papa und tochter
jetzt aufgehört haben werden wir gegen
ein neues team antreten nämlich nur noch
nicht wer und wo und warum und wie aber
na ja wir werden am dienstag antreten
montag ich am feiertag kaiser
pfingstmontag und am dienstag sind wir
dann mit abstand der mit uns dann auf
jeden fall bauen brücken immer fleißig
zdf einschalten weil während am dienstag
kochen schon ganz aufgeregt sind auf
jeden fall noch mal herzlichen
glückwunsch an das team das heute
gewonnen hat wir sind einerseits ja
einerseits schade dass sie nicht
weitergemacht habt ihr jetzt bestimmt
geschafft andererseits gut für uns weil
es uns gegen mit
das team antreten will erstmal bei der
fälle und jetzt immer einfach gespannt
gegen wen wir haben dienstag kochen ja
was
der warenkorb sieht ja etwas na ja nicht
so megatoll aus stubenküken und was wars
kabarett habe ich noch nie in meinem
leben gemacht wir werden einfach gucken
was draus machen ja leider keine zeit
zum üben weil wir noch über das
wochenende im schwarzwald fahren unseren
freunden und natürlich sehen uns dann
erst am montag wieder da werden wir dann
schon nach hamburg reisen und dann
schauen wir einfach mal was wir drauf
machen
afrikanische mentalität genau auf jeden
fall müsst ihr uns die daumen drücken
einschalten am dienstag um 15 auf 5 im
kindes- und wir werden dort antreten
dann wünschen wir euch ein schönes
wochenende
wir holen uns gut geht warum paar
erholsame tag im kreis unserer lieben
und eingeflogen und ich werde noch
schauen dass sich übers wochenende ein
paar videos hochladen
mindestens das muss auch schokolade
thorsten video eventuell noch das
zitronen torten video mal schauen wie
ich es zeitlich schaffe man wer weg sind
und dann sehen wir uns ja auch dienstag
live und in farbe
ich werd dann auf jeden fall meine
kamera mitnehmen nicht einmal ob ich
vielleicht vorher filmen kann und danach
und währenddessen keine ahnung wie immer
hinter den kulissen aussieht vielleicht
vielleicht interessiert euch das jahr
ich werde einfach schauen wenn ich zeit
habe und sich die gelegenheit bietet
immer mal wieder dass er halt auch an
unseren erfahrungen teilhaben können das
wollen wir ja auch gerne und freuen uns
schon drauf und machen dass wir uns da
dann sehen wir uns bei
aus dem papier
sie bekommen ja kommt mir das hier ist
kein platz
unterbleibt bleibt